deschamps pour exprimer leur colère en
slovaquie ils étaient plusieurs milliers
ce mardi à défiler dans les rues de la
capitale bratislava une marche contre le
renforcement des restrictions qui met en
lumière la perte de confiance du peuple
slovaque
envers son gouvernement et ce malgré
l'appel de la présidente à rester unis
il n'y a pas de slovaquie pour ou contre
les masques pour ou contre des mesures
strictes nous sommes une seule nation un
seul pays une seule communauté comme en
novembre 1989
nous ferons mieux face aux défis
d'aujourd'hui si nous sommes unis une
manifestation lourde de sens puisqu'elle
se tient le jour du 31e anniversaire de
la révolution de velours
une date symbolique synonyme de lutte
pour la liberté et la démocratie
face aux forces de l'ordre déployées les
manifestants dénoncent avant tout un
retrait pur et simple de leur liberté
une très mauvaise chose s'est produite
en slovaquie les masses qu'ils ont tous
fermé et les gens n'ont plus de travail
parce qu'on leur a tout pris le premier
ministre igor matovic a beaucoup
d'argent bien sûr il ya des entreprises
et tout ce que vous voulez je ne sais
pas même s'ils ne travaillent pas
pendant un an il aura assez d'argent
mais ces gens ici n'en auront pas le
gouvernement
il se passe ici des choses qu'ils ne se
produiraient normalement pas
droits de l'homme et notre constitution
sont violées et ils disent que c'est à
cause de l'attenté nous sommes tristes
j'ai 59 ans je n'ai jamais protesté
contre quoi que ce soit jusqu'à présent
matteau vie qui m'a forcé à descendre
dans la rue depuis pusher à bratislava
malheureusement même constat en
république tchèque où des milliers de
manifestants ont bravé l'interdiction de
rassemblements sans masque et ignorant
les règles de distanciation sociale en
vigueur
ces protestataires ont élevé la voix
contre leur gouvernement
certains ont brandi des pancartes
réclamant la démission des membres de
l'exécutif
et tandis que certains scandent leur
besoin de liberté
d'autres militent pour le droit à
l'éducation
c'est le cas de ces étudiants italiens
qui protestent face au parlement à rome
affublés de masques représentant
certains dirigeants ils réclament une
revalorisation de l'enseignement pour
eux l'école doit figurer en tête du
programme de l'exécutif
malgré la crise aujourd'hui nous
organisons une leçon en portant des
masques représentant certains de nos
législateurs nous ne voulons pas aux
français ni nos pieds de qui que ce soit
mais nous voulons souligner que nous
devons commencer à trouver de nouvelles
façons d'investir dans les écoles
publiques ne demandons pas de reprendre
l'enseignement en personne à partir de
demain matin bien sûr nous ne sommes pas
aveugles et nous sommes tous conscients
de la situation sanitaire en italie mais
nous demandons que l'éducation
redevienne une priorité le plus
rapidement possible en europe il zone la
plus touchée dans le monde en nombre de
cas les pays semblent unanimes quant à
l'importance de durcir les restrictions
dernier exemple en date la suède
pourtant à contre courant depuis le
début de la pandémie
le pays a décidé pour la première fois
de limiter les rassemblements publics à
huit personnes